downtown strip
the hope is they're searching for
survivors the reality the fear they're
looking for bodies so I'm looking around
town
and I'm saying
I know we can rebuild
but what you do with the devastation
what you doing over here
[Laughter]
the tornado has landed on Friday night
ripping a trail of death and destruction
through 270 kilometers of the Southern
U.S state of Mississippi changing the
landscape changing lives as you can see
that truck there that's
my brother he's a truck driver
all of those trucks right there are his
trucks
so his whole livelihood is just sitting
in a pile of dirt
emergency help is now putting in doing
what they can where they can I want to
take the opportunity to personally thank
all of the volunteers that are here what
we've seen over the last 36 hours in
Mississippi on the one hand has been
heartbreaking to see the loss and
Devastation of these communities but on
the other hand has been inspiring
tornadoes have always been a problem in
this part of the country there's nothing
to indicate they're getting stronger or
there's more of them but one top U.S
official says areas like Mississippi
have to be built to be more resilient we
see extreme weather events increasing
only increasing in gravity in severity
and in frequency and we have to build
our communities to be best prepared
for them to prevent the devastation to
the extent possible to be able to
quickly respond and recover to prove
ourselves resilient the White House has
approved federal aid for the area that
will bring temporary housing money for
repairs and low-cost loans to cover
uninsured losses people have started to
return to recover what they can where
they can rebuilding Starts Now
recovering from the loss of life and
property that will take much longer Alan
Fisher Al Jazeera